le feu a en partie ravagé le bâtiment et
sa toiture
mais c'est à l'extérieur que l'on peut
mesurer l'intensité de l'incendié sur
l'espace de stockage des matériaux à
recycler les métaux et les plastiques
triés par les compagnons d'emmaüs n'ont
pas résisté à la chaleur c'est des
cintres alors on le démonte le mythe
deux des big bag après on le voit à
l'entreprise qu'il qui le problème la
matière et comme si ces as après le feu
avec la chaleur alors maintenant satrape
arte à la cnra teurs un manque à gagner
pour la communauté d'emmaüs de
norges-la-ville dans le bâtiment
sinistré
un périmètre de sécurité interdit
l'accès à la zone la plus fragilisée
choqués les compagnons qui travaillent
ici une vingtaine de personnes était là
ce matin
aujourd'hui je pense et demain on va
s'arrêter parce qu'on peut pas l'accès
des dowler dollon gare par contre on va
continuer à l'extérieur on voir
trottiner l'extérieur faire des choses
l'association des compagnons d'emmaüs
relativise les dégâts matériels sont
importants mais on ne déplore aucune
victime
pour commencer à déblayer les décombres
il faudra maintenant attendre le passage
des experts d'assurance on est bien
assurée donc quand je pense que ça
pourra repartir au bout d'un certain
temps mais il y aura un arrêt une craie
tour fort heureusement le feu ne s'est
pas propagé à l'autre partie de
l'entrepôt où étaient stockées des
produits inflammables et des engins de
chantier pour la communauté emmaüs de
norges-la-ville le pire a donc été évité